laurie lachlan will be celebrating
halloween behind bars
definitely no treat to be there the full
house star
has reported to prison a full 20 days
before she had to
laurie started her two-month sentence
today surrendering herself to
authorities at the prison in dublin
california
it's about 40 miles east of san
francisco the same facility where
actress felicity huffman
served 11 days of her two-week sentence
so why now well lori successfully dodged
a media frenzy by reporting early on the
friday before a big holiday
and the election the big question
what will life be like behind bars for
the full house star
i had a hair person a makeup person i'm
gonna miss all my persons
it is a huge adjustment to go from a
multi-million dollar
home into privacy to living in a tiny
space
lori will be strip searched
fingerprinted and issued a standard
uniform what will
laurie's life be like day in day out so
like all federal prisoners lori is going
to
have a job it could be scrubbing toilets
working in the dining room
lori will be allowed to shower once a
day and she'll eat with the other
inmates
she's going to go to the chow hall if
she likes three times a day
but there's another twist today while
lori adjusts to life behind bars
her daughter bella just made her music
video debut
[Music]
the 22 year old holds a pistol in griff
clawson's new music video for
chasing highs the video was directed by
brett nassek
a source tells e.t bella has wanted to
follow in her mother's footsteps for
years
she and her sister olivia jade visited
lori on the sets of summerland
and fuller house and bella played
alongside her mom in a hallmark
christmas movie
i gave you the santa suite i hope you
like it so acting classic is that
something
that you see yourself pursuing yeah i
think i think so yeah sweet finish
go to college then you can do what you
want so i want them to be happy so i
want to be supportive of everything they
want to do but i do want them to have
somewhat of a normal you know finish out
high school college experience
that college experience was of course
cut short
after their parents were implicated in
the admission scandal
after completing her prison sentence
lori will be under supervised release
for two years
you